[Music]
if you lost your hair would you consider
doing something like this
yeah they look that good hi I'm Nick I'm
a business analyst here at BuzzFeed and
I'm here to get a hair piece I first
looked started losing my hair when I was
21 I had a little bit of a panic attack
and when I started noticing it it's
progressively thinned until I was about
25 and then I decided that it was time
to shave it all off and I've been going
bald for the last few years when I was
in college my hair was thinning and my
now wife she was known for being the one
who's dating that 30 year old it's one
of those things where you feel your
mortality a bit quicker I think it hits
young like the mortality side and it
also hits you on just not feeling
physically attractive I think it's
affected my life in a few ways I'm not
confident I don't feel like I need
confidence to do the things that I want
to do it's shaped me to be a very
analytical and introspective person my
wife's always been really supportive
about it my hair has never been an issue
to her and I feel like I've never
understood why that is but I'm happy
that it is so my son is 3 and he's very
honest he always jokes around but like
that he has no hair everything so I
think it'll be interesting to see his
reaction so I'm getting the hair piece
put on tomorrow I am nervous that people
are gonna like how the hair piece looks
and that I will feel obligated to
continue wearing it in order to feel
attractive to other people rather than
feel attractive to myself I think I
wanted to see what I would look like
with hair and I think I also wanted an
excuse to try it doing a video at
BuzzFeed is a great excuse to try
something you're afraid of hi I'm
Michael doing this and I'm here with one
head applying a piece to a bald man if
you take care of it you can get a good
four plus months out of them
I think these pieces are awesome because
it does give you confidence not everyone
can be blessed with a good head of hair
I'm a hairdresser I need to have my hair
so if I were to need it I would
absolutely
the millisecond the piece touches his
head it will not move so you cannot make
a mistake
[Music]
I'm excited this was different
[Music]
whoa the moment I saw myself in the
mirror I was feeling overwhelmed not
only did I have new hair but I had a
hairstyle but I wasn't used to I thought
it would be like getting in a time
machine this is not how I used to style
it but this is probably how I'd want to
style it in 2019 I'm curious to see what
my co-workers and friends and family all
think I'm trying to get used to this
this is really weird to have hair
it's a lot of hair and it's I've never
had this much hair I do not hate it
it just didn't feel like me it felt like
I had a new arm put on it felt like
something completely brand new I feel
like it's gonna be a big change for my
co-workers and my wife and family I know
I have to go like talk to my co-workers
and like see their reactions and like I
didn't know exactly what to expect with
it thank you
you look different but the same the same
time if you lost your hair would you
consider doing something like this yeah
they look back in they were really cool
about it I was opposed to be like your
new haircut what's so cool I think the
initial like jarring like I suddenly
grew hair reaction generally kind of
fade it into like I can't tell that
wake up tomorrow morning I'm trying to
get used to this
it's
honestly like in my initial reaction I
was feeling a little like this thing is
not bright and then like now I'm
actually liking it a lot
that couldn't be honestly the first one
but I'm starting to like it so after
work I went home to see my wife for the
first time and I went through the door
she was sitting on the sofa and big
smile and laugh and like she's like it
looks good you know and one of the
things like I discovered through this
whole process is that she actually likes
me best with like fuzz on the side and
being bald on top and I did not think
that she actually liked that so that was
actually a really interesting thing to
uncover I got home too late to see my
son that night but he woke up the next
morning and I woke him up and asked him
about my hair and he took a second you
can see like he's like looking at my
hair and trying to figure out what's
going on is anything different about
daddy
the hair do you like it do you you just
immediately wanted to play barbershop
you give me okay hey that's it I'm gonna
sit down the barbershop chair okay I'm
ready to go chief my son always wants to
play barbershop but I've never had hair
for him to like home or anything like
that he had a lot of fun like combing my
hair and like pretending to cut it which
is really fun it was really interesting
like shampooing my hair for the first
time it felt like part of my head it
didn't feel like it was something that I
needed to be especially delicate with
and I still really don't have to feel
very delicate with I've thrown out all
my shampoo like I haven't had shampoo in
years I went to go use my what I felt
was my wife's shampoo she zero-waste so
everything is in these little bottles
and I didn't know that I was actually
using body wash the first time I
shampooed my hair the stasi is this I've
been making a lot of trips to buy things
I forgot that you needed to take care of
hair so actually when I bought a comb
for the first time in many many years
so the haircut they gave me looked
really great but it wasn't something
that I would
where my hammer like I've always kind of
done this like chin where Bing thing
where like you kind of like whip it up
in the front styling it that way made it
feel a lot more like what I would style
my hair like this would be the first
time I might have helmet hair in years
let's see how bad it is so I was really
worried about biking to work what my
hair would look like after being in a
helmet and getting all sweaty and
everything ah not too bad I also took an
Instagram poll I asked people did hair
Nick or bald Nick have better music
taste and a 70% of people said the bald
Nick had better music taste which same
dude but apparently this haircut has I'd
given some bad music evacuation past so
it's been about two weeks since I got
this hair system put on it was really
jarring it was not what I was expecting
but as I like wore it and like saw how
people reacted I got a lot more
comfortable with it and I really like
how it looks like I do feel like I'm
treated differently in public a little
bit I've noticed like fleeting glances
from other people that I really haven't
picked up on before and I like I kind of
like that I've been thinking about like
how my confidence has changed throughout
this process and likes I think I do look
more attractive and like that is a
really cool thing to experience I think
I used to think of confidence as like
this like ego driven thing that is like
it's a functional things and like I've
always discounted the value of
confidence I realize now that like I'd
like catching my reflection in a mirror
and I liked thinking about myself as
like representing my age so all
throughout this process I've been trying
to decide like am I gonna keep this hair
am I going to
we're a hair system for the rest of my
life and like I decided that I don't
have to like weld it to my head like I
can freely move between how I feel it's
really cool to be able to just be able
to play with my identity and I felt like
before this like I had to be like
visually consistent and dependable and
like I have to represent the identity
that is given by my genetics and like
how I naturally express myself and I
realized in this that like I have a lot
more control than I thought I can choose
how I look and how I interact with the
world and like that is a really cool
thing to have
[Music]